-This is very exciting.
We were talking backstage.
You´re actually out here not
just to do my show.
Thank you very much
for doing that.
But you´re taking
your daughter to colleges.
-My daughter Erin and I
did the little college tour
from Boston to New York,
and it´s been
a wonderful opportunity.
Any parents,
if you have the chance,
it´s a great time to --
great way to spend time
with my daughter,
and figure out
new ways to embarrass her.
-Oh, that´s nice.
[ Laughter ]
Have you found any good ones?
-Yes, I have.
I´ve got a great one!
She´s always been embarrassed
by people recognizing me,
so that´s great.
I just, you know,
look like myself.
That does the job.
[ Laughter ]
But also --
This is because
I´m an older guy, I think.
I don´t have time
to figure stuff out.
I just want
the world to tell me.
I´m gonna die.
[ Light laughter ]
So, we pull in to Boston.
I roll the window down,
"Where´s Harvard?!"
[ Laughter ]
"What building
do I have to go to?
Give me a name!"
[ Laughter ]
"Thank you.
That guy was no help at all."
Yeah, just to strangers,
and she cringes.
-And does that age a person
recognize you?
College kids?
-Most people -- Oh!
College kids
love "Better Call Saul,"
but a weird thing happened
where, uh...
we were touring one school,
and we had two fine young women
who were showing us around,
and they were both majors in TV.
One of them knew me.
The other had never heard of me.
[ Laughter ]
Or the show, and I grabbed my
daughter, "We´re out of here!"
[ Laughter ]
"Pathetic!"
-You --
I love this show so much.
I feel like it´s such
a high level of difficulty
to do this prequel,
and for you, as an actor,
you know this destination
of eventually becoming...
-Saul Goodman.
-...Saul Goodman,
who has no morals.
-Yes.
-And you have kind of started --
Jimmy McGill had some morals,
and they´re sort of eroding.
-He´s a good man.
-He starts as
a dimensional character,
and then he becomes
one-dimensional.
-Yeah. You lose --
And is it hard
to, like, sort of --
´Cause it must be a little sad
to sort of see
your character lose his --
-Yes, it is, absolutely.
And, in fact,
this third season,
which just ended,
and I hope you´ve seen it.
Spoiler alert, I guess.
He really takes
a big step forward
to becoming this character
of Saul Goodman,
who you met in "Breaking Bad,"
and it bummed me out.
And I´ve been one,
for this whole time, going,
"Let´s go!
Let´s move this thing along!"
And then, when the character
does this thing
where he hurts
this old woman´s feelings
at a senior-citizen home...
[ Laughter ]
...played by Irene --
character named Irene Landry,
played by Jean Effron,
a great actress,
and he sort of
intentionally ostracizes her
from the other people
at the home.
And I called the person
who runs the show, Peter Gould,
and I said,
"Does he have to do this?"
[ Laughter ]
And he goes, "Bob, the show
is called ´Better Call Saul.´
I don´t know
if you´ve seen ´Breaking Bad,´
but you have
to become that guy."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"Yeah, you´re right."
-The other thing
you had to do this year
that I heard was difficult
is you had to eat
a lot of Doritos.
-Oh, yeah. We had a scene
where I ate Doritos.
And, usually,
if you do that on a show,
they get you
the healthy version or whatever.
I haven´t had a Dorito
in 30 years.
I´ve actually
smoked pot more recently.
[ Laughter ]
And, usually, you would think
those two go together.
-Yeah.
-But, uh...
[ Light laughter ]
But, uh...
I --
They had Doritos.
I said, "Sure. I´ll take
a bullet for the show."
And, man, I ate a Dorito,
and my brain exploded.
[ Laughter ]
And every single take --
and we do a lot of takes --
ended with, "Cut!"
and me going,
"Oh, my God, that´s good!
[ Laughter ]
"How do they do it?!"
It´s like...
[ Applause ]
Wow!
I don´t know whether that means
you should eat them
all the time
or you should wait 30 years
and then eat a bag --
an entire bag.
-Did you have any,
like, residual
the next day without Doritos?
Was that a hard day?
-It was a tough day.
[ Laughter ]
I cried.
I cried all day.
-Well, now you got
to go another 30 years.
That´s gonna be a long --
So, congratulations
on your Emmy nomination.
It´s so well-deserved.
-Thank you.
-Truly is.
-Hey, listen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I just have to say
a shout-out to my cast members,
Rhea Seehorn, who´s amazing,
and Jonathan Banks,
who´s also nominated, wonderful.
And Michael McKean...
-Michael McKean.
-...who this year --
[ Applause ]
-Just...
You don´t --
You can´t be better than that.
-Can´t be better.
Yet he, sadly,
was not nominated.
I´m gonna call it a snub.
I´m gonna say it´s a snub.
-Yeah. All right.
-I don´t know why.
-He´s wonderful.
The show is wonderful.
Thank you
so much for being here.
Really appreciate it.
Bob Odenkirk, everybody!